how do you guys so sorry about that we
got a very important phone call that we
had to pause the street and for because
business never stops turning here at the
morning toast but we're back we got a
very important phone call coming our
reservation right you know you just we
need to just take a break because like
the world doesn't stop turning so just
ignore tell all your friends we're back
only on YouTube for today because
Facebook sucks and they're trying to
ruin our careers right they're trying to
take you to down with them and it's like
we're not interested
we'll see you on November 28th not pause
not like the thing yeah you look so
pretty
nah anyways we were just popping off
into our Fast Five story so let's take
it from the top with our number one
story I will now be reading this
headline for the fourth time today but
you know what it's never enough preach
for each ercell bow who's People's
Sexiest Man Alive in 2018 it's an ego
boost for sure he says thoughts I'm
happy that the Hollywood is finally
recognizing the true talent and beauty
of the aegis elbow because he's been
wronged so many times and he's had to
make his own career path period well I
just feel like this is one year too late
because even though I was in the
minority who enjoyed Blake Shelton's
appearance last year know and was very
small but a very small minority
including Blake Shelton himself who
didn't understand why he was on the
cover and we agreed but it should have
been easier sell but last year I think
so now they're writing this wrong great
I was really hoping that this year would
be Jason Momoa but because Aquaman still
hasn't come out even though it's been
got to be next year it'll have to be
next year because I all we have to go
off of his sexiness is that one scene
from the trailer where he's like up to
his wasting water and turns around with
his shirt off like I haven't even seen
that and I'm so immersed in pop culture
right so I feel like next year will be
the year of Jason Momoa and in the
meantime we can enjoy the year of Aegis
Elba a very deserved award yeah and
honestly like ever since they promised I
know I'm repeating myself I just don't
know if people heard the first time ever
since they said they were gonna make him
bond and then didn't like [ __ ] everyone
okay right whoop okay would you rather
be bond or People's Sexiest Man Alive
bond totally Zak because like People's
Sexiest Man Alive does it even come with
a paycheck no and also like it's just
for so many reasons
II just
needs to be bond one like we're just
deserving of it too it's like not even
believable anymore that pierce brosnan
who has to like get his hip replaced
between movies is like jumping between
trains fighting spies like it's just
unrealistic at this point and I can't
suspend that much disbelief have you
ever even seen a Bond movie yeah of
course Adele you saw the movie
double-oh-seven I saw when he's sitting
in the chair and they keep kicking him
in the penis it's like so me and that's
sad I've never seen a Bond movie it's
like so not our genre we never you know
more documentary type features feature
will do and even though action is not
our genre you don't know I was thinking
about a movie that an action movie that
technically isn't my genre but I
thoroughly enjoy and I hope they make a
sequel to the sequel a third a sequel to
the sequel Kingsman they did made a
sequel they made a sequel I hope they
make a third is what I'm saying you know
I never saw it this sequel is just as
good as the first one like if not better
I and has like Channing Tatum and is
really good stuff the guy who plays like
the main character is like a generic
version of like six other actors that I
know he's like good oh my god I'm having
gas in my throat today he's having a
bird he's like dave franco he's also
that guy you know Margo who's the guy
the guy you know he's like the brown
haired actor he's like a young guy he's
in like a like a hungry sick 8000 type
of like franchise the tech not as
popular or as well-known where he's like
running through a wall like Harry Potter
diverging who's the guy hey Ansel Elgort
no no I know I know what you're talking
about action but give me his name he he
looks like dave Franco like the guy from
Kingsman is like they hire him to be the
stunt double for the other guy
intelligent he's like divergent his name
is Theo James show me how using the
steel of course he's an actor I'll text
you and a doctor the air drop it to me
snitch anyways back to eater Salva I
hope he thoroughly enjoys the title and
yeah I can't think of people so I sneeze
man alive without thinking that episode
of don't trust the B in apartment 23
when Chloe Dylan O'Brien oh my god why
not Dylan O Brien oh no you're now back
to the Kingsmen kid looks like yes I
think he looks exactly like a breakup
wait let me see hold on
that's nice runner no no that might have
been the worst call you've ever met a
maid
wait no no thank you no no it's the Maze
Runner holdup Margo I don't even know
the double J's runner know who the [ __ ]
did you just say James I don't know what
any of these people are and I don't care
okay The Maze Runner yes what's his name
it's Dylan O'Brien that's horrible call
now the kid from the Kings man hold on
Kingsman he's way cooler and manlier
little Brian is like oh my god yeah this
is such a good call okay the guy who
plays the Kingsmen King whatever his job
is the spy in training is Dylan O'Brien
no he's not
where's Colin I'm uh I fell upon this
conspiracy theory like surrett it wasn't
a conspiracy it's like this insider
threat about toe strips seventh album
it's coming out in July apparently and
it's like I just really need my chillers
of conspiracy theory podcast to [ __ ]
launch ready because I have to talk
about the thread aren't you in charge of
launching it it's like not at all cuz if
I would have recorded it on my phone in
my bathroom and just like released it
why don't you sue it cuz like the
network and the art right
that's oh my god snitch just air drop me
photos of these guys I see it's they're
just like white and young and it's that
other guy this is Kingsman Taron Egerton
that's I can't it I can't talk about
these people anymore like if we're not
talking about all the chris's being the
same I'm not interested for two seconds
I can't talk about these things of
people that I don't [ __ ] know okay
Dylan O'Brien like from that terrible
Netflix movie and ruin Britt Robertson
acting chops like please scram
next up Spice Girls reuniting for a
summer 2019 tour without Victoria
Beckham so it's not actually a Spice
Girls reunion cuz these four would I
think spicy about it these four would
reunite for the opening of an envelope
these four would be unite for honestly
like a paycheck of like $700 display
people of the world get ready to spice
up your life because the basis II oh
that was a good reference
[Music]
hi-yah what size which do you know that
song
yeah first okay spice world season was
like probably one of the best movies
like of our generation like on every
level on a music level on a fashion
level on a comedy level I hear someone's
own action movie level when that big bus
has to go over the bridge so in my
physics class in the eleventh grade we
had to put together a project where you
took like a scene from a movie or a TV
show and you would measure the velocity
of like the rate that the car is going
so I did the velocity of the Spice Girls
touring tour bus going over the London
Bridge and like if it actually could
have pulled off and I notice in the
movie they did it as a cartoon like it's
not a real bridge it's literally like a
toy car that's funny but if I did if it
was real would like however much a tour
bus double-decker tour bus typically
weighs and like a London Bridge and the
speed I wrote they would have had to
been going like 800 miles per hour to
have made it over the bridge so they
were going 800 miles per hour and this
is a terrible example in my teacher miss
Bravo was like very in tune with what's
at starting she like loved it that's
great yeah she was a great teacher like
oh it's just like making me excited
about science
she should teach on Skillshare a decade
after the last tour and months of
teasing fans later years of teasing fans
later like the ladies are officially
hitting the road once again for a newly
announced tour while you say you'll be
there we do have a bit of bad news as
one of the five og Spice Girls will be
missing this time around posh spice
Victoria background because she actually
made a career for herself quote today
marks a special day for the girls as
they announced the first tour date since
we performed together in 2012 I won't be
joining my girls onstage again but being
in the Spice Girls was a hugely
important part of my life and I wish
them so much love and fun as they go
back on tour next year she wrote on
social media I know they will put on an
amazing show in the fantastic fans and
present past and present are going to
have a wonderful time I mean something's
fishy is going on like
I notice what they'll be dressed up as
yeah okay she dressed up as Victoria
Beckham with a sign that says never
going on to her right so I guess that
was a promotional thing for the tour I
don't know something about it's just
ringing sad to me well here's the thing
about all this stuff
it's like Victoria Beckham has a life
and a career and like I don't know if I
would be like jumping on the bandwagon
for something that happened 20 years ago
when I'm literally like the face of my
own successful brand right and nor
should you but I don't think it's
considered a reunion if you don't get
all the members back here's the thing
sorry I'm just I'm taking it there's
some drama like I wanted text what is
going on nothing just like a little
birthday surprise don't worry about it
okay here's the thing and I will you see
I always say here's the thing what I
don't have anything here's the thing the
thing is is that while I don't think
that it's a reunion without Victoria
Beckham when she was a Spice Girl she
wasn't necessarily like the best one
like vocally so I think they could
really pull it off without her it's just
like a cultural thing like do we need
that no I don't think that we need that
they're only going on tour in the UK
which I think proves that they realize
that this might not be like the the
blockbuster they were hoping for I can't
even drink like without spill are you
okay this show is like so [ __ ] up - I
know but like those are the best shows
are they yeah I don't know well I had
something else I want to tell you okay
so you're really in charge of monitoring
the Facebook group like in terms of
letting people in I never do but I was
getting a mágico trying my nails and I
was bored I'm like let me you know let
me try and they didn't realize that you
changed the entry questions - like are
you a Claudia or are you Jackie and it
was so interesting to like hear what
people think of us and like what the
traits that they like like relate to yes
so for you it was like I'm obsessed with
all things beauty but like I'm really a
grandma yes that's like I didn't even
realize that that's what you are no it's
like the things that people point out
about you and I it's interesting like
what we're most known for to them and
like for you it's like outgoing no
filter dog mom right no it's like my mom
who has a dog like is a Claudia or
anyone who's like very loud and like
annoying is a Claudia and then anyone
who has red hair is automatically a
journey and anyone who like whereas
Selene like grandma shoes is also a
Jackie
yes and has stopped drinking I once went
to Cleveland yes I believe to Cleveland
and loves a Pinot Grigio girl yes Pete I
listen to that song this morning it's
one of the underrated songs on Joanne
the whole album is underrated yes also
speaking him to face the group we are
letting in new members I just trained
the snitch last night to know to start
accepting members or declining showing
her what what you should look for and
you should start bothering snitch
you should bother both of us she hasn't
started yet but now she knows what to do
we went through a couple samples I
tested her I was like would you let this
person in what yes before
okay ideal profile okay so how then no
but the people who are watching should
be in the group I drew I wouldn't know I
grew I can't even talk first of all any
in-depth answers that show that you have
been watching the show for a while and
you know again two of us necessary will
get you into the group there's no right
or wrong answers actually there are some
wrong answers the first question is
what's your favorite toast
inside joke toast is capitalized I don't
want answers from the old show that is
an automatic dough but so would you
consider Claudia I'm flat broke so
because of the October 1st episode there
are people who applied right after
October 1st and so that's their answer
but typically that answer doesn't get
you in and then I look to hear other two
answers and sometimes to see if it's
reflective of your toastiness right and
a lot of people like I no longer accept
that as an acceptable answer it's not
like them decline automatically but now
it's not accept automatically got it you
know well it's like annoying like that
annoying people have to ruin it for us
because like I think those levy and like
that's an answer that you could find
like on reddit or something like so I
want to see yes I'm sure your maybe your
favorite inside joke is grab a spoon but
like show me that you really know this
show right and like it's just
frustrating cuz there's 3,000 requests
right now and I want to let them all in
like I just I every time I come I get
like I do a mean green at a show that
I've let me into the girl but my mind
you came to my show and you're not even
in the group like you deserve it but
there's no way for us like retro
actively like search yeah you can when
people say let my friend in the group
her name is Katie fine I can't search
people's names so Stacy but it's not
help like I want to let your friend in
the group trust me but until Facebook
lets you search requests I can't do
anything for Katie so it's just like
frustrating and they'll just have to
like people will just have to wait the
Facebook group is more secure than the
CIA it is but not as secure as the TI 8
Oh
okay have we only done one story or is
that - no that's - because the Spice
Girls okay so like tbh however one I
didn't - let the dream die I'm sorry I'm
like the biggest Spice Girls fan but
it's like I've been hearing about a
reunion since I was like 13 oh and
remember when the Olympics were in the
UK and they like sang a song together
and everyone was asleep and they said
they were launching a tour I've been
hearing about a Spice Girls reunion tour
like since I was 12 I honestly would
rather see like a young fit cover band
doing Spice Girls songs oh yeah nobody
unsprayed lay like impersonators yes
like I would see them before I see like
these girls without posh singing song
singing old songs and and not dancing or
like and probably let's say it's a group
of friends like on Halloween
like shut singing sorry I'm interested
or like Little Mix
doing like a set of songs where they
dress up as the Spice Girls such as
their five little mix or four is only
four but now there's only four Spice
Girls I'm if you could do away with any
spice girl who would it be okay well
here's the thing I would say sporty
except after Spice Girls she was the
only one who had a solo career and Rhys
released the greatest song what oh my
god
Margot what's that song whoo I'm Elsie
hold on hold on you know what hold on
Mel C song I guess now I understand oh
it's 11:11 make away I turn to you
that's gonna smell feigning towards the
Sun I turn to nineties a green song
maybe she'll go Maggie over solo career
it's a lovin lovin Make A Wish get your
bag get your bag get your bag beat you I
beat you back we should angry - angry -
Magby - Magby - ahead get your bag Gucci
bag Gucci bag Gucci bag you're alive get
your bag with your bag with your bag bag
bag did you get your line back I'm lying
a little but it's present I turn to you
like a flower leaning to words son I'm
sorry but it it says Gucci bag Gucci bag
Gucci bag this bag get your bag get your
bag [ __ ] your bag douche bag I'm dead
it's like oh my god this is beautiful I
know this is from you yes just me nobody
else contributed oh actually actually
the toasters multiple times reached out
and they were like we're gonna gather
money from everyone and get Jackie a
Gucci bag and I was like first of all
Jackie could never accept a present as
extravagant on behalf of the toasters
and two I already got it so sad
oh my god I just love you this on
multiple occasions I took like refund
people's money okay the toasters tried I
love you guys and thank you sister this
is so nice and now that this is the
toast ask believe receive so next up we
are getting wicked revived with Ariana
Grande and no one next 1111 tomorrow
we're wishing for a wicked revival and
we're also wishing for Network Show
Network show Network show Network show
Network show Network show network that
was hard to wait speaking of Network
shows I the past few nights I've really
hold on let me get rid of all this
tissue I really been checking out the
competition what do you consider okay
obviously busy tonight even though like
panels in comparison um lady hang on
watch last night two nights ago and then
nightly pop which I was already asleep
so last night I watched the first
episode which was last week and the
second episode which was this week which
was last night and I watched with Zach
and it's so good and Morgan Stewart is
it's Leigh Allen is the Barbara Walters
of our generation because not only is
she so funny on daily pop but it's also
it's easy to be funny when you're not
being the host the serious one it's like
Jerry O'Connell show we're like he does
all the structure and then his guests
get to be funny
totally so it's easy for her to be funny
on daily pop so like what are her
hosting chops she hosts nightly pops she
reads from the teleprompter she does all
the conversation we know that it's not
an easy food and she's so cute and funny
and she really can do it all and also
like that was watching he was like wow
she's really good at reading from the
tender beautiful could she be more
beautiful I can the more stylish just so
funny I'm relatable and I really think
she's gonna do amazing things what do
you think keeps her up at night because
she seemingly has the perfect life I I
think what keeps her finite is like is
nightly pop gonna take off because if it
doesn't then it's like that's that's
it's a lot of she got a lot of that it's
a setback for her in it and it shows
maybe she can't helm her own show even
though she can
and like this show could be everything
um what else keeps her up at night I
feel like she definitely even though
she's like skinny and perfect and
beautiful she definitely like thinks
about what she's eating oh you know and
she said on richkids of Beverly Hills
she was chubby when she was a kid and
she was like teased endlessly about it
and I think even once the first season
of rich kids she wasn't as like thin as
she is now so she definitely works at
dieting and losing weight so that's
something that would keep people up at
night I can't live I just got this toy
for Theo because it's keeping him like
so intact and it's basically a bone
where you hide a treat inside and he
spends six hours trying to get the treat
yeah look at him he's going nuts and we
do know that like she's had some like
fractured friendships true Bravo juicy
rocks he's engaged yes she looks
I mean her ring is so beautiful and her
husband fiance is so cute and he's like
a trillionaire good for her yeah and
like you know I'm really happy for her
Scotty yeah cuz like this is his dream
like he is a Salvati sister and he
pretends that he is and I'm just like
really happy for him and like he's gonna
be the probably the maid of honor oh
that's so cute yeah happy for him
anyways I recommend Knightley poppin
anything we're gonna sue or does and I
just like I feel like she's such a good
representation of our generation yeah
and then I agree the Barbara Walters of
our generation is a blanket statement
for sure but I think a safe one no but
the Barbara Walters of her generation
she was just like the go-to host and now
that's change with social media you have
to be funny and quirky and the followers
and that's just read off the
teleprompter do anything Morgan Stewart
is all of those things yeah I mean
anyone can read off the teleprompter
except for anyone ever Joey okay next
story we finished each other's
sandwiches Mac Miller's death ruled
accidental overdose of fentanyl cocaine
and alcohol Mac Miller's death has been
ruled as an accidental overdose the LA
County Department of Medical Examiner
coroner confirms to Yahoo entered haman
Tipton that the rapper died from mixed
drug toxicity after finding fentanyl
cocaine and alcohol in his system
what's fentanyl um speed how is that
different than cocaine I truly don't
know I don't know the difference between
a lot of drugs like what's the
difference between heroin and crack I
think when you smoke heroin you know
crack is smoking cocaine
cocaine crack ho or in I don't know yeah
drugs are new and but you can also shoot
heroin but I think that smoking it is
worse for you I don't know really I
think shooting it has to be like the
worst sounds worse but then it gets into
your lungs oh well guess it's your
bloodstream I don't know we don't know
anything about drugs but it sounded seen
as an ad it was an accidental overdose
like makes it even sadder every chef
could say thank you to Malcolm because
he was an angel honestly any time I
think Ariana's like it's starting to
annoy me now with like all of this press
but like any time I think about the Mac
Miller but all like it makes me really
sad it makes me really sad but if he
hadn't passed away like then we were
saying this the other day let that like
in death like you become like legend
iconic right and if he had him passed
away he would just be like her ex who's
like I didn't eat her up yeah it wasn't
a good like fit for her right so it's
easy to look back and like in hindsight
favorably but we have to remember like
the things she was saying while he was
alive fentanyl isn't opioid yeah that's
how a lot of overdose has happened
people say that's prince was hooked on
opioids and actually was just sitting at
the nail salon and I started reading a
People magazine that said Jamie Lee
Curtis was addicted to opioids yes she
was he was she was on the cover how she
Oh cover how I overcame my opioid
addiction but it's cute
I'm not cute I'm sorry I was looking at
do and I was like oh that's good and
then the opioid addiction is not you in
turn is having a rough time the oh he
wants attention and that exact term is
having a rough time we must get through
the rest of the show yeah we must also
because Marx launches in 40 minutes
merge merge merge merge merge go to
shout morning toast what I'm talk about
the March is like the morning to us is
really a sorority it's the sorority most
of us were never in it's excluding
myself because technically I wasn't us
right but I'm not at liberty to talk
about it um you know yeah I know it's
like so big and now I'm in a sorority
that I can talk about proudly and wear a
shirt out in public I know a sorority is
truly the perfect way to describe the
toaster it's like when I try to explain
to people like I used the frit I use
cult but coach has like a negative
connotation it's like we're brain
matching people and and it's yeah it has
a negative connotation even though the
toast doesn't but it's only needed to
describe like our sisterhood
yes sorority is exists er hood of
sisters who aren't
that's what our merch is really
reflective like of the merch Evette when
you enter a Delta Kappa Phi so I know
you're considering a lot of other houses
but please rush toast
ya won't regret it yeah we'll give you
our bid everyone gets a bit thanks a
thing and when I take it like pictures
that meet and greets but like big groups
I always say I'm like I feel like I'm in
a sorority like what's art you know
everyone has like a oh we did lists
before what is ours I think but that's
no not like I want like a you know like
what about toast that looks like a
little Heil Hitler vibes but in a way I
imagine everyone's like no but it's you
have to keep your arm bent that's the
key one like a [ __ ]
1 2 3 no you have to raise your glass
yeah that's cute that's my cue yeah
that's a cute one
yo that's cute ok that's cute yo so I'm
wearing toast on three one a toast on
three one two three toast you're still
like going what do you have to scoop
into it you you would spill your drink
like that what were you doing like this
- Kimmy want you - one two three
toast okay this next story we've tried
not to talk about because we're not
giving this relationship the platform
that it's so severely wants but I can no
longer not talk about it because I'm in
shock okay
Priyanka Chopra's Bachelorette weekend
wardrobe featured feathers sequins and
lots of Bridal brain bling ever since
Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas announced
their engagement
she's been embracing a bridal like
wardrobe and for her epic bachelorette
party in Amsterdam she kept her
bride-to-be theme going in a series of
show-stopping white dresses Chopra
kicked off the weekend in a white
sweater dress with feathery appliques a
white coat and over the needs snakeskin
boots she's seen sipping from a drink
out of two plastic straws and honestly
I've never related to a bit more in my
life then she switched things up on the
second day ditching white and opting for
an orange and pink sweater with a plaid
skirt but she kept the Bachelorette
vibes going by accessorizing with a
bride-to-be sash and fascinator okay you
guys I have something to say about these
two about Nick and Priyanka
tell us they are going to go the
distance they're going to get married
they're just that thirsty and they might
even have children and they're never
going to give up on this farce and the
reason why is because it's
easy to be in a relationship with
someone when there's nothin there's no
like emotion in the game like this is a
business transaction for both of them
that is proving to be quite fruitful so
yes of course I will invest more in the
business so she is going so ham well the
thing and it's almost like she's just
like becoming like a professional bride
it doesn't even matter who she's engaged
to this has nothing to do with Nick and
just Priyanka the bride so I like it's
so funny because like I'm very in tune
with what's going on in pop culture and
Priyanka is at the forefront of it and
like I never would have known that she
went on her bachelorette party I only
know because I follow so be Turner on
Instagram and she's like being a good
sister and as being there I didn't see
that Danielle Jonas was there did you
know is she pregnant
oh maybe where did they go because the
pictures that I saw on Sophie Turner's
look like [ __ ] like Amsterdam oh they
did yeah oh I guess that yeah you
guessed Europe because it did look like
Europe I just feel like I guess when
you're celebrity it's different he just
like grab a plane and go anywhere but
Badger weekends are supposed to be like
a two three day thing like you shouldn't
have to travel 12 hours yeah and like
the gun is my [ __ ] am certainly
giveth Olivia my sister one of my best
friends in this world was like I'm
having my bachelor party in Europe I
would say have a good time have a great
time I won't be there yeah you know what
that's so Priyanka but I mean it is I
was surprised Megan wasn't there I was
not because she couldn't but I if she
was there would have been like wow she
went she's a good friend but maybe she
slept in for a meal but they're really
best friends I think yes they were best
friends before Megan was even a royal
because they were both like thirsty like
cable an extra network actresses and now
that they're both I guess chillon of
society the friendship is even more
beneficial your chair today looks like
it's been like electrocuted with
balloons I you know my hair too
oh my god yes oh my god the helium is
like lifting up your hair that's why
your hair sticking up but you can't see
it on the show we're not quality let me
go back to my batter then oh but you
brushed your hair up against the blue
stuff oh oh uh
so anyways Nick and Priyanka will
definitely be getting married and I
think soon because she's already had her
bridal shower her bachelorette party
their engagement party I've heard you
before your private shower I guess it
depends I honestly think that they will
be married like perhaps by the end
wow that would be crazy what if they're
doing a New Year's wedding I wonder
which one won't go do then those or
sisters I think I'm gonna go to our
sisters because I like to support real
love yes not just finance I receive I
need a dress for Olivia's wedding and
I'm just having a hard time so if you
know of a beautiful burgundy dress that
has sleeves and can flatter a busty
sized woman I would just appreciate it
any an email sorry I'm having such a
high shopping today so maybe you'll find
something new I gained two pounds of can
become one of those girls you look
wonderful
no and honestly like I think it's mean
to try on any sort of clothes when you
ever period oh yeah because it you bet
then you have to buy like it's just not
right yet we saw one sorry I don't know
I put my iPad away and is it a story
that I requested um no what sorry did
you request reason to relate oh it's
hard to do a story on the video I know
how I feel about that uh oh iPads
tweaking out okay so the story is was so
Amazon has been teasing everyone for
literally a year now where they're gonna
put their second headquarters cuz
whatever it's at whatever city they
choose will bring new jobs away young
people yeah like it's been a really good
first headquarters mm I think so
somewhere techy its if only we had an
intern who was listening to the show to
look things up that we add I really hope
that you're on your home carrying cancer
right now because like what are you
doing yeah okay okay but snitch like we
need to know what did we need where is
the Amazon current headquarters and then
I'm gonna tell you what they're planning
for HQ tube because I even remember when
I was in Dallas I was talking to tax
grandparents and they were talking about
how they were in the running Dallas is
in the running for HQ to see okay that
makes sense they're in the running for a
human like how it bring so many like new
young people so many jobs it would it's
gonna boost whatever kind of mountain is
is to go to so have they decided is that
the story they've they've decided is it
a lot down what is it the company is
nearing a deal to move to to splitting
up HQ to spread in the loved one to Long
Island City Queens according to two of
the people briefed on the discussions
and they're also close to a deal to move
the second one to Arlington virgin
a Washington suburb Amazon already has
more employees in those two areas than
anywhere else outside of Seattle its
home-based and the Bay Area but like I'm
not here for this first of all New York
they do not normally grow anything more
we don't need more people no like New
York is you know the capital of the
world so if Amazon is doing something it
should be here especially you know with
the decline of Wall Street you know
people are just saying like how many
people are gonna work in this thing and
like live in the city and take the
subway and be in cabs and just like
cause more congestion right and all
they're like Amazon chart shipping out
Detroit well then we'll get our [ __ ]
really quickly oh my god totally they
need to open in Long Island City because
there's a lot of space like an Amazon
mega warehouse we're like if you need
something that day you can go well
that's what I it seems as if they're
doing with HQ - oh really like you can
we'll be able to go buy like a store you
can go oh no no no it's not it's not
retail
it's just HQ - but they need it doesn't
have to be retail but they need a
warehouse where they ship stuff out from
that you can also go and chop at it's
like you can't like needed that day
honestly like not to make this about
myself but they really should have I
don't I'm not here for this decision I'm
not here for splitting it up either
because I feel like whatever they could
have really revitalized the city and I
feel like they should have gone with
Cleveland of course by the way in
Kardashian's this week when they were
doing the podcast from Cleveland Scott
definitely respects your opinion on
Cleveland yeah and Chloe definitely
knows my opinion on Cleveland but or
they could have brought it to like a
city that needs it like Detroit that
could use like the boost and economy use
the boost in jobs like not already
flourishing city like New York right so
I don't know I'm not totally here for
this decision but I do trust and respect
amazon's process so i'm sure like but
you know have them let us astray this
far like why would they start now right
so it is what it is ladies will say
we'll say say now I've been waiting for
this for 48 hours we are about to talk
about the greatest movie of our time
three identical strangers a documentary
about oh so the mister looks okay I've
never watched it honestly I would turn
this off because it's such a great film
that I don't really want you to be
spoiled
turn this off that log on to shot
morning toast at noon yeah also follow
me on Instagram
I thought over - I know but they're
leaving okay
Instagram I'd like to hit 140k today I'm
really not that far so if I don't and
that's [ __ ] embarrassing
I haven't posted a birthday picture yet
but when I do just make sure to like it
and that's where you can leave me your
birthday wishes and just tell me
everything you want me to see I'll read
all the comments and what else thank you
everyone for contributing to my Gucci
bag and like spirit you know and yeah it
was not financially no no because they
wanted to and then they their spirit was
so sweet
that's really so sweet thank you all for
watching I was like oh my god like I
could never let you know but like I love
you okay so I was in the airport and I
read in the back of People magazine this
story which apparently is a very popular
story from the 80s like in the news I
never heard about it but in the 80s like
everyone knew about it because there
were these three twin triplet brothers
who at the age of like 18 were reunited
after being separated at birth they
found each other like one two of them
went to the same College I need the news
and have a third one song and the third
one saw the two of them on the news and
was like oh my god I'm related to them
I'm also adopted and I look exactly like
them so the three of them found each
other and it was so happy and it was so
crazy and just like so the documentary
has two of the brothers talking telling
the story of like how they were reunited
how they met what how they grew up and
then once they found the third brother
they were like launched to start him
they had a restaurant they were in
movies they were celebrities they were
dating
every 54 that part of the movie was like
amazing
no and the guests get it get it that's
what would happen like now if something
like this were happening it kind of
reminds me of like Mason Ramsey like
it's just something so pure so pure like
just going viral and if Mason Ramsey
we're an adult which then he wouldn't
have gone viral because the fun of it is
that he's a kid it's just like this is
how he's been received in the world and
so they were adults so like they're
hitting up studio 54 talk of the town
and just loving each other getting to
know each other and finding out like oh
these things that they have in common so
like these three boys who were robbed of
so much of their childhood like we're
just launched to this like happy
fun-loving family stardom and they start
their parents were like furious that
they didn't know that the brothers had
two triplet brothers and they started
doing research and they were gonna hire
a lawyer they went to the agency Louise
wise agency which was the
Jewish adoption agency in New York at
the time there so there was only one and
they were like why didn't you tell us
that they had that they were triple s
and they were like well we thought we
wouldn't be able to place triplets so we
separated them and put them in different
homes so that everyone can have a home
which seems benign and even when they
left like they knew there was more to
the story and they tried to hire a
lawyer to like investigate and to sue
and every predominant lawyer in New York
took the case and then subsequently drop
them which led the parents to believe
that like there's something going on and
there's real like powerful people
involved so it turns out that the the
separating of the three twins was a part
of a study a study performed by dr.
Peter neubauer who was a [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] who separated many sets of 20 sets
of twins and we only recently found out
that it was that many sets because dr.
Nuvo word is death is dead and his study
is now housed at Yale University and is
archived until 2026 86 when presumably
all of the people involved will have
passed away so it's which is they were
studied from childhood and it was an
experiment on nature versus nurture
these three people are naturally all the
same but they were raised in different
environments and the kicker is because
you think they're testing the twins like
they're testing the triplets like
they're coming in their house they're
under stairs studying them they want to
see how they are but when you find out
what they're really testing is the
parents that they had placed daughters
in all of these homes to find out the
different parenting styles and then they
placed one of one triplet in a strict
home in a traditional home in one right
in the middle and one in like a modern
home um and they studied the effects of
different parenting I'm essentially the
same person right and so the reason my
only two out of the three of the
brothers are in the documentary is
because one of the brothers after they
rose to fame they like went back to
normal life they all got married started
having kids they had a restaurant
together the restaurant the other one of
the brothers suffered from mental
illness and committed suicide and it
turns out that their birth mother
suffered from mental illness and she
definitely inherited that from her as
did some of the other birth mothers from
twins that were separated so then it's
not only are they testing nature
nursery on parenting styles but they're
also using children who are predisposed
to mental illness one trying to see if
mental illness is not as nature or is it
nurture like is it something that you're
born with or is it something that
circumstances might right be together
who did commit suicide grew up in a home
where it's like his family they weren't
very like overtly like intimate actually
affectionate thank you that's where and
I'd the thing I didn't like or agree
with the movie it's like they tried to a
little bit shift blame to his parents
about him committing suicide like that
they weren't affection and then say I
love you enough and like it's not like
he grew up in a bad home like his his
dad was in the documentary he was like a
lovely guy he was a teacher he just
wasn't like mushy gushy lovey
also in terms of parenting styles they
were also so see a different brain was
rich one was poor was the middle class
so using all of those different things
to understand like how we why we are the
way we are right and basically the whole
study was like is it nature or nurture
and then the conclusion of the study
which we'll never get but the conclusion
that all the doctors in the film made
was like sometimes its nature and you
know sometimes it's nurture great we
knew that already chewed to ruin all
these people's lives but in the middle
of the movie when they talk to that
woman who's in Ha [ __ ] la jolla and
now he was his research assistant for
many years she's oh my god still alive
she is the not say she is it not she's
not Jewish is she I'm so crazy is that
this study was conducted by Jews on Jews
which is just so you want to crime a Jew
on Jew crime and it's so I can't believe
something like this would happen in the
modern era like post Holocaust with
connected by someone who escaped the
Holocaust and it's it's like Mengele
[ __ ] and then the brother said they were
like this is some Nazi [ __ ] when you
start experimenting with like human
lives and and just like trying to play
God you are a Nazi the La Jolla [ __ ]
was so they're not remorseful like it's
like you know when they do like you know
there's like literally three living
Nazis like in America and the people
like throw eggs outside their house and
like you see them like living their
lives it's like how can you live your
life when you killed six million people
like how does that woman live with her
pictures of her and Michelle Obama like
and not know what she did and then they
had another research assistant who was
only there for a year and he was normal
he was like I was doing the work I
wasn't really involved
I used to go
these people's houses and like do the
studies and like go from one brother to
the next and then they didn't even know
they had brothers and he was like I left
after Eric cuz I just thought it was
weird like that's a [ __ ] normal react
and he gave us like some more
information as to how many people were
there and the notes that he took but he
was only there for ten months and the
woman the old woman from La Jolla who's
[ __ ] scary [ __ ] was like saying in
the middle of the movie it really is all
nature like you can't you think you have
agency and free will but now it doesn't
it suck to know that you don't like and
I was in the middle of the movie I let
her know that guy was like wow it really
is all nature and then by the end of the
movie after understanding what they did
and like how all these three boys were
essentially the same in raising
different environments and we were
saying how considering their predisposed
to mental illness and some of the other
brothers did suffer from it as well and
they were separated from each other in
the crib as sensually at six months old
imagine like being I mean you can't
imagine it because you're not if you're
gonna wear when you're a child but like
you have two people beside you in the
room for in the womb and for six months
after and then those people are just
gone and you're alone and that like
[ __ ] with you psychologically on top of
being genetically predisposed to mental
illness and then you are in a home that
is in a completely right fit for you
right but that's not any adoption agency
but like I don't know that but come all
these factors together it's like what
did you think was gonna happen so stupid
so [ __ ] up we didn't get any results
and so Yale okay all the paperwork is
under lock and key at Yale they have
released like ten pieces of paper to the
families and people who have been
affected and it has nothing in it and it
has information redacted to protect
other people that were part of the study
who still don't know that they were part
of a study and that they have a twin out
there so so there we know that there are
thirteen sets of twins and then that
eleven of them have been found right so
there are still two sets of twins out
there and we think no one who don't know
that they're twins and we think we know
one so the reason why Jackie really got
like [ __ ] hyped on this is and when I
was watching the movie I was thinking a
lot about Ben's mom Ben's mom was
adopted and I know she was adopted she
was born Jewish and adopted into a
Jewish family which I know was like kind
of rare and it was because she was in
this like very well-known
Jewish adoption agency and I was like oh
that's so weird like maybe it was this
one and the whole time and Ben's mom is
like she is very intuitive like when I
was in Mexico and that lamp went on and
I saw a ghost like we called her like
she's very clairvoyant she's she
definitely is in the middle of the world
it's like she it has a spot right there
in the middle she's like Theresa the
Long Island medium and when I was
watching the movie I was like oh my god
like I wouldn't be surprised if Ben's
mom Ava had a twin because maybe that
intuition that she feels is this other
person that that she knows and I'm like
maybe she's at the same agency so I
called Ben immediately when I landed
because I watched and I called you
immediately when I watch it I'm a Ben
watch it and he asked his mom she was
from the lobby spies agency she was born
in July and August 1961 and the boys the
TWiT the triplets were born July August
1961 so a months difference I was in the
nursery with them yeah so I was oh and
so right okay I was freaking out so we
went to dinner two nights when I was
asking her a million questions and she's
like so open about it she like wants to
hear this story and she met her birth
mom like many years after she was
adopted and she knows her birth sisters
so like there's no way that she could be
a twin because like her birth matter
what would have told her been like
where's your sister so she's she's not
but Ava was adopted with a brother so it
also makes me think that like because
all the boys had sisters so much maybe
her brother and her brother it was
adapted from the Levi's as well right so
now I'm like getting involved in other
people's business that's like not my
business but like I'm telling you we
think we know I'm Chuck I can't believe
I can't believe it I know I can't
believe it like oh and another Oh two
things that Ava told me that freaked me
out when she said she has very vivid
memories of when she was a kid of people
coming over and like observing her
family which is what they did to the
kids in the study - she said her book
birth mom was very friendly with the
triplets birth mom oh my god I'm [ __ ]
shook her burthen was from oh my
goodness sorry I thought you met her
adoptive mom
with the the triplets adopted parents we
gotta bring around the toast we have to
bring Avon the toast we have to crack
this case wide open
and then there's still one more set of
twins that have yet to be oh sorry
she also told me it was like her and
Bruce Ben's dad were like in Vicky on
vacation somewhere like in Vermont and
they were at this market and she saw
someone and she was like oh my god looks
just like my brother like she was like
freaked out so she went over and she was
like are you adopted by chance like I
know that's really weird
and the guy was like so weird I was like
what no and then like ran away so did
she
she fishy stuff so at the end of the day
I think in the in the debate of nature
versus nurture and everyone says it's
both I think like your nature is like
how you are the way you are like your
mannerisms and when they were doing all
those interviews where it's like we
smoke the same cigarettes and we like
have the same taste in girls it's like
yeah you're also 20 years old so living
there or how they all lived in New York
right 20 years old growing up in the
same like neighborhood essentially you
I'm sure there's a number one cigarette
brand out there and to like I'm sure you
all have the same taste in hot girls
yeah yes it's like you know it's like
the things that they were asking it's
like oh my god they're so similar but
it's like what people weren't focusing
on where their difference is right which
I think we're were because of how they
were raised
yeah what your purse snatcher so I think
I've never thought about it that much
because I've always really thought it is
both yeah it is um I think nurture
sometimes can overcome nature but
sometimes nature can overcome inertia
like the way that they were walking and
talking was also similar and and that is
nature because like they all have the
same like gait and that's just how
they're born that's like in their DNA
and they're very similar and they look
similar and that's the nature of it all
and they have similarities because
they're triplets but they have so many
tips I think all their differences come
from the nurture you know all the things
that they were different eyes were
nurture overriding each honestly the
like the chubbier brother in the
documentary like I found him so cute and
good-looking I like wanted to set him up
with someone and his dad like I was
crying so much when he was like when my
dad fell I was was that what they call
him Pamela so when my dad found out he
was so heartbroken like he would he won
he would have wanted to adopt all three
of us and he was the poor family was
wrath so it was just like so it's not
about like they always say like
you know having so many kids it's like
an expensive thing but it's like it's
not about how much it's like a love
thing oh my god I just absolutely
distraught like it's a tough movie to
watch on a plane because you're just
like left with your thoughts after we
write and I was thoughtful full of
thoughts and then the the Nazi in Hawaii
was like when she was talking about the
two sets of twins that still haven't
been you reunited it's like on the one
hand they should know there'd have a
twin out there but on the other hand
it's caused everyone all this sadness
maybe they just shouldn't know what
imaginary Sara Lee know if it would make
them feel better no but like they have
to know imagine entering the world with
someone and then never ever seeing them
again that just goes against everything
that God intended it was such a terrible
movie well so there were so many sets of
Jewish twins born in that one year right
totally who knew how did the Louise Y's
Agency have access that like you need to
know about yourself but you need to know
like that I did did you 2:23 me ever so
I just sent in my kid because I did my
swab I ordered the kids so long ago and
then I sat on it for a while just
because I'm lazy I did my swab which is
pink with my lipstick in it yeah um so
they'll definitely get a hint of color
pop cosmetically and I just said that'll
come back to you related to the
Kardashians when I sent it in when I did
it was like right after the hurricane
and headquarters are in North Carolina
and I just didn't wanted to get lost in
the mail so I waited and I just sent it
in and I'm so excited and curious to
find out my results because I know a lot
of you guys think that I'm adopted
breaky is right here maybe we'll find
out that you are right and but I mean I
would have said yeah maybe we'll find
out that I am except when I took those
pictures in a black wig I was literally
Olivia yeah that's true and also we're
just too similar but maybe that's not
you know I do my 23andme maybe like a
year ago I did it when me and Ben we're
getting married because I wanted to find
out if we were related which you are
which I think there's one a dream II
didn't explicitly say it but it pretty
much confirmed that we are cuz I came
back 99.9% Jewish Eastern European and
Ben came back a hundred percent I feel
like I'm two percent Jewish Eastern
European I feel like nobody's a hundred
percent like that really freaks me out
and I only did it because my friend on
and Rachel their dad was like bragging
to everywhere he was like I was
percent nobody has ever been like we
cover like a very very organized Jewish
community he was I'm higher than
everyone I got 98% can you believe it
can you believe it I was like actually
coming um I got 99.9 percent and then
Ben Keynes Ben's results came back he's
like I got a hundred I was like are you
kidding oh my god I'm so excited to get
my kit back and see how we're similar
nature and nurture also did you know
they 23andme is named for the 23
chromosomes that make up our DNA
obviously they know that because I'm not
that smart right but now you just
learned something every day anyway
interesting I would encourage so many
people you're 23 me and I think that now
it was astonishing
I really look hard to see where where I
come from there's your early something
about me that's different than you meet
you yes so what is it are I think no
we're not Irish but we do have some
South African no is it Finland we do
have any Dennison some Finnish in our
Bloods men like you are the reason I
left so maybe I'll find out that I'm
predominantly finished by now through
Thanksgiving 23andme and stress Tree
Service kits are only $49 per kit when
you buy two or more kits that's 50% off
the original the regular pro kit price
of $99 this holiday yeah order your 20
yes I did it Lester during holiday
season because it was on sale
yes me too and that's how long I've
waited I've slept on this order your
23andme and trustee kit at 23andme calm
/ toast that's 2 3 a and DME comm saj
toast you guys like I know open your
eyes it'll open your eyes and maybe
you'll find out that you have a twin so
be cool
I also 23andme could be the last piece
to the puzzle on the triplets I'm the
the twig my separated
if this twin thing had happened today
23andme would be all over it like
sponsoring their whole tour total
patient oh my god do you see 23andme on
Kardashian and course what a seamless
integration not unlike ours so it is
11:45 you have 15 minutes getting your
credit cards go to shop morning toast
calm the password will be removed it'll
be open you don't need pretty self
repaid trend members there are unlimited
quantities you have 24 hours noon today
til noon tomorrow to get your pop
sockets your hats your rings your
sweatshirts your t-shirts your long
sleeve shirts I'm gonna have an address
he's telling the
guy he died very sad and join the
morning toaster already because it's
time we made it official you guys fresh
toast we are gonna take care of
everything make sure there's no kinks
let's take Shopify down people go to
shop more Neto so calm in 15 minutes you
have 24 hours to buy all the merch that
you want there are no refunds and all
items shipped within two weeks and sizes
go from small to two exhales because we
are not [ __ ] and I need the two XL
so I needed to make yeah me too so I
could wear it as a dress thank you thank
you thank you bye guys we'll see you has
were they to me shot wearing toast for
my birthday present that's all I want
you